investors are keeping a close eye on
Tesla's stock this morning after CEO
Elon Musk made controversial comments on
last night 60 Minutes musk lashed out at
the Securities and Exchange Commission
in the wake of a settlement with
regulators requiring the board to
monitor his Twitter account he told
Leslie Stahl he does not respect the SEC
and indicated he's still tweeting with
no oversight Kris Van Cleave is at a
Tesla dealership in Washington DC with
more on this story Chris good morning
good morning you may remember Musk was
charged with securities fraud by the SEC
back in September that was after he
tweeted that he had secured funding to
take Tesla private the agency alleged
that mislead shareholders now this 60
minutes interview was raising questions
at Musk plans to comply with the
restrictions the SEC is putting on his
social media have you had any of your
tweets censored since the settlement no
none does someone have to read them
before they go out no so your tweets are
not supervised the only tweets that
would have to be saved reviewed would be
if if a tweet had a probability of
causing a movement in the stock Sunday
night on 60 minutes
Tesla founder Elon Musk appeared to
bristle at the new SEC restrictions on
his Twitter account but but how did they
know if it's gonna move the market if
they're not reading all of them before
you send them oh I guess we might make
some mistakes who knows it was perfect
no III want to be clear I do not respect
the SEC I do not respect them but but
you're abiding by the settlement aren't
you because I respect the justice system
oh it's classic Elon he's known to fight
public battles against people that he
feels like have wronged him or are in
his way Wall Street Journal reporter Tim
Higgins has covered Tesla for years he
says so far musk has not appeared to
violate the terms of the settlement the
company has until the end of the year to
put policies in place to overseas
communications but the board faces a
challenge because a big part of Tesla's
success is tied to musk out
persona because you got the Elon Musk
magic especially on Twitter it's really
hard for a board to pull Elon Musk back
he is the visionary for the company
Tesla says it will comply with the
settlement but that only gives the
company three weeks 21 days to get the
policy in place to pre-approve relevant
musk tweets the SEC declined to comment
on that 60 minutes interview
bianna it was quite an interview Chris
thank you